the Ukrainian missiles strike hits
Russia's Naval headquarters in Crimea
attacks on the russian-controlled
territory have intensified just as
Ukraine's ground offensive in the East
makes little Headway so why is Crimea so
important to both sides this is Inside
Story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
I'm Laura Kyle
russian-controlled Crimea has been
coming under increasing attack from
Ukraine the territory annexed by Moscow
nine years ago is now an active
Battlefront between in the war between
the two once seen as a fortress of
moscow's military might the latest
attack in sevastopol has shown Ukraine
is capable of reaching targets far
beyond the front lines there's
speculation that British or French
missiles helped score a direct hit on
the Russian naval headquarters on Friday
one of moscow's most important bases
we'll ask our guests in just a moment
why Crimea is so significant to both
sides first Finton Monahan has this
report on Friday's attack
foreign
at the heart of Russia's operations in
the Black Sea Ukraine says Friday's
attack on the Russian Regional Naval
headquarters in Sebastopol killed
several high-ranking military commanders
the bases in Crimea well behind Russian
lines
it came as President Vladimir zielinski
wrapped up a trip to North America
Ukraine's allies have been ramping up
shipments of advanced weapons that make
it possible to strike deep into
russian-held territory
we are grateful to the United States and
with all due respect to all of our
allies United States provides the
largest share of assistance the
assistance that our soldiers on the
battlefield really need at this moment
so we are discussing all the different
types of weapons long-range weapons
artillery and air defense systems
speaking at the U.N Russia's foreign
minister accused Western powers of using
Ukraine to fight a proxy war
factitious skill
the west art de facto fighting against
using the hands and bodies of ukrainians
I think everybody present here who pays
at least some attention to the situation
in Ukraine knows very well that
Americans britons and others are
fighting and those countries are
providing more and more weapons
all right
along the front line of the conflict
Ukraine's progress has been slow a much
anticipated counter-offensive has failed
to make significant gains in retaking
territory held by Russia
but the strike against Sebastopol has
shown that Ukraine can hit Russian
assets far from the main Battlefront
and if attacks like this can be repeated
it could open up a new front in the war
Vincent Monaghan for Inside Story
well there's been a series of attacks on
Crimea leading up to the latest strikes
on September 14th Ukrainian forces used
a combination of drones and missiles to
knock out a surface-to-air missile
system and just one day earlier
long-range cruise missiles damaged a
naval ship and a submarine a dry dock
for Fleet Maintenance was also hit and
is expected to be out of action for
months and on October the 23rd an attack
near the town of olinifka destroyed
another air defense system and a radar
station
[Music]
thank you
let's bring in our guests now and in
Moscow Andre baklanov Deputy chairman of
the association of Russian diplomats
he's also a former Russian ambassador to
Saudi Arabia in London domatila
sagromoso senior lecturer in security
and development at King's College London
and the author of Russian imperialism
Revisited from disengagement to hegemony
and in New York Michael borsaku senior
fellow at the Atlantic Council and a
former spokesman for the osce special
monitoring mission to Ukraine a very
warm welcome to all of you Michael let's
start with you that the black Fleet
headquarters it's a major high profile
Target how did Ukraine pull off this
attack
sure well um look you referred to the
correspondent referred to that area as a
military Fortress but we're seeing
because of Ukrainian attacks it's
nothing more than a sandcastle even
that's kind of a compliment I mean the
fact that the Russian uh sorry the fact
that the Ukrainian Rockets were able to
penetrate the highly vanted s-400
Russian air defense system is absolutely
astounding look these are systems that
countries like turkey and India have
paid billions of dollars for and now
we're seeing that it's largely
ineffective not only protecting their
Crimean Peninsula but also the Aerospace
in Moscow against fairly rudimentary
drones so huge success for the Ukrainian
forces but if I can I mean we have to
remember also The Wider picture that
Crimea is very very important strategic
for three reasons historic uh economic
and Military and economically uh
everyone's looking at this and these
this day and age with oil and gas
reserves but there's a lot there and as
well previous to Russians Russia's
illegal annexation or Crimea they were
paying billions of dollars of rent to
Ukraine so
if you put all of that together it's
very strategic and then I should also
add I am temporarily based in Odessa we
think of Crimea a lot for several
reasons but one of the reasons is that
it is the base for these Russian
missiles being launched and targeting
not only Odessa but the ports and a
critical component of the global food
supply chain so when Ukraine does strike
Crimea it's not only for its own
military reasons defensive reasons but
also because it is keeping the world's
food supply chain in mind okay Michael
thank you there's a lot to get into
there in this discussion first of all
Andre let's get your response here this
is the latest in a string of attacks
that we've seen in Crimea how big a blow
is this to Russia's Black Sea Fleet
uh okay I think this is a very serious
uh development of the Affairs
here in this war
but uh actually we're expecting Southern
Market
and uh that's been that's why a long
time ago we decided to quiet our
headquarters and I add and uh other
sensitive objects uh
um in the territory of currently in some
other places and of course this was the
globe not to the people that are working
in the headquarters but to the building
but at the same time it's a very serious
thing I think that uh well uh all
countries in the world they are lacking
efficient uh empty
the new system against the so-called
plans all systems are only in the start
of the developing so well it's quite
National that uh many objects uh will
feel a danger that the development of
the Affairs so so this is the reality of
the present day uh
expected this attack why did it not
better defend its Black Sea Fleet
headquarters
I think that the only uh real effective
way of Defending against such attacks
it's uh you know starting the basis the
basis of this striking facilities of the
Ukraine I think it will it will happen
in some other uh so I I'm not quite sure
that uh it was uh well uh it was not a
certain restraint a certain restraint in
our military uh you know tactics uh
perhaps it was not very much wise policy
we should have the opportunity to strike
against these bases a long time ago
saying there that this attack was to be
expected that it didn't come as a
surprise do you agree with that
yes I think that it is clear that
already now for several months if not
over a year that uh you know the
ukrainians have been trying to um weaken
uh Russia's military presence uh in
Crimea for obvious reasons as was
explained by the first best speaker uh
the fact that from Crimea there is
always a challenge on the sort of north
western coast of Ukraine on the Black
Sea and that's where a lot of the grain
uh is being exported so Russia um for
Ukraine it's very important to make sure
that there isn't a sort of a landing
opportunity on the shores of Odessa and
these these shores of of Ukraine at the
same time uh Crimea is the seat uh in
Sebastopol of the Black Sea Fleet of
Russia and it is from uh from this Fleet
that a lot of the missiles are being
fired at Ukrainian infrastructure when
uh a lot of the from from uh ships or
submarines that are sibo on but they're
based in the in the Crimean base at
sevastopol so this is also a very
important point to try to diminish the
ability of Russia to hit at uh Ukraine
at the mainland and the infrastructure
so I think that it's it's something that
you know was to be you know I mean was
talked about for quite some time and
we've seen many operations already last
year when there were attacks on on the
basis that Russia had the the air bases
that Russia has uh in in Crimea
Andre President Putin has always said
that Rush that Crimea is a red line that
must be crossed
so how will he respond to this because
we now keep seeing Crimea being hit
well we are expecting that there will be
another phase uh in the development of
the military Affairs and uh there will
be much more attacks against the
Ukrainian facilities uh air bases uh and
uh well uh we facilities dealing with
the electricity and uh Etc you know well
uh actually we have been doing this but
not on the level that will give the
opportunity to make the victory in uh in
the in this certain period of time for
several months I think that will it will
need no less than two years because the
quantity of the troops are very limited
when we were liberating Ukraine in the
second world war we had 12 times more
truth than we are carrying now on the
territory of Ukraine so this is a not a
limited quantity in comparison even with
the quantity of the troops that the
ukrainians or three government circles
so well well I think that the strategy
is to prepare ourselves now uh not for
the war against the the key regime but
with the war with the NATO because this
is a prelimited stage of this kind of
the confidence the main thing is now to
say the troops and give them opportunity
to gain the necessary experience real
battle experience these are these are
the main elements of the strategy okay
Michael I'll just give you a chance to
respond there to what Andre says before
bringing us back to Crimea uh less than
two years before Russia sees victory in
Ukraine what's your response to that
um that would be a miracle by any
standard they are not doing well on
several front lines uh whether it's
land-based the long front line that
stretches from north of Ukraine to the
South but also obviously in Crimea and
also uh able being able to protect its
own skies I mean I'm also wondering how
does the average Russian think about
this whether they live in Crimea or they
live in the outskirts of Moscow or even
Central Moscow that they are now getting
a taste of what ukrainians throughout
Ukraine face every day this barrage of
missiles and drones so I I wonder what
this means for Mr Putin's uh hold on
power
the other thing uh we should say uh is
that uh what Russia has done with Crimea
in the past decades is the uh fits into
a pattern of not only disregarding its
own International bilateral treaties but
also of cultural genocide what's been
done in Crimea to the uh Crimean tartars
either killing them or deporting them to
places like Siberia so we are saying
that a Russian playbook play out now in
the war with Ukraine but once again
um they are performing very badly on the
battlefield poor morale of troops
they're losing
um soldiers at two or three to one to
the Ukrainian side and one more quick
thing is with the introduction of these
uh more powerful longer range missiles
like the storm shuttle from the UK and
the attackings which are expected to
come you can probably expect a rajling
up probably it could even include it
could even include a direct strike on
the Kirch Bridge which is an important
resupply chain in the whole war effort I
think with these newer missiles it would
not only
um put a hole in the bridge but put it
out completely and again we have to
emphasize this these these resupply
rates are legitimate military targets
don't tell her Michael raises the point
there wondering what people in Crimea
think of all this it must be pointed out
must note that polls have consistently
shown that more than half of the
population in Crimea favor unification
with Russia this is a broadly Russian
ethnically Russian population
um I think it's very important to
highlight two points first that in 1991
when Ukraine had a referendum on
Independence the majority of people in
Crimea voted in favor it wasn't an uh a
resounding majority as in other parts of
Ukraine but nevertheless it was majority
if I'm not mistaken of around 57 percent
and that also included the city of
Sebastopol so when ukrainians had a
chance to vote in an open uh sort of
referendum they did vote in favor of
Ukraine's uh Independence in Crimea as
well and what is important to highlight
is also the fact that the referendum
that was carried out in 2014 was not
really free and fair and the opinion
polls are very hard to uh to add to sort
of evaluate so I wouldn't I wouldn't
base myself on that I mean of course we
know that there are sympathies and
generally there is a mood in support of
of integration with Russia but that in
know doesn't justify the annexation nor
does it allow Russia to operate in the
way it does in the region especially
because Crimea has become really a seed
of military operations for Russia if we
must remember the the the major Souls
that was carried out in February 20
um 22 into Ukraine was carried out from
Crimea so Crimea became really strategic
as a base for military operations and
also for Russia it has been a you know
control of Crimea has allowed it to
really sort of close the Sea of us off
to Ukraine's grain exports and all kinds
of other in industrial exports on the
western uh call excuse me on the eastern
northern coast of Ukraine's Black Sea so
there are very many arguments in favor
for uh you know as I said for Ukraine to
try to retake control over Crimea I
think what is also important if we talk
about people I think remember the
cranium tattoos they are originally many
of them have been forced to leave
there's been deportations during the
Soviet era and they were not really
allowed to return even um even when
other peoples were allowed to return to
their areas of origin the tatas were not
so there's been a lot of sort of in a
way cleansing of populations that are
originally from Pioneer and many
Russians are really first generation
there they're not there since many
generations in Crimea
Andre why did President Vladimir Putin
Annex Crimea in 2014 it was seen to be
illegal under international law and it
started on a collision course with
Ukraine and the whole world
well actually after 19 uh
1991 uh we didn't expect that Premier
will return back to Russian Federation
we didn't have it in mind it was uh what
happened in 2014 this is the
development of the Affairs because of
the change of the regime in Kiev this
forceful change
and after that the regime started you
know intimidation of the people living
in Korea so we had to put an end on that
because the regime took to be really
fascist as it was during the second
world war during the war in Ukraine we
had more than 1.5 million uh over uh
traitors traitors that collaborated with
the Nazi after that we put them in
prison but unfortunately in 1955
khrushok uh
for them to return and that was the
start the start of the present day
tragedy where we are having and remember
that 11 11 millions of ukrainians are
living in the Russian Federation and
they are breaking everything and I was
visiting for several occasions Premiere
I was assure you that the population
there including ukrainians they are uh
well happy that they will return back to
the normal situation uh together with
the Russian it's not the division
between the Russians and ukrainians the
the division uh between us and this
regime that took power in 2014 and uh
these people that collaborate in this
regime their grandsons of the tractors
and the parents that were in in the
territory of Ukraine during the second
World War
do you accept though that Russia's
annexation of Crimea is illegal under
international law
yeah uh it was absolutely legal exactly
at this Western Country saying about
Kosovo the people fed up with this
regime and they decided to return back
to Russia we didn't have these plans
that told you this is absolutely legal
and we are not taken seriously the
arguments the people are giving that did
not visit Crimea did not know anything
which is happening there what they are
saying some of our colleagues they even
here and the TV they are you know
giving us some stories where they did
they took the figures where they took
their opinions did they have the
opportunity to know what is going on
this Earth these are fantasies and
propaganda that the government of the
United States are preparing for their
citizens and the citizens and some of
the countries including the so-called
ukrainians
Michael what's your response to that are
the people in Crimea they wanted to join
Russia after the fall of Victor
Yanukovych and the rise of zelenski and
a more pro-western government in Kiev is
that the way you see it
that's complete nonsense and um I think
I don't want to dignify
um the individual who just spoke uh by
responding to his Twisted version of
History the lies the the fake news
um I will just raise one point here and
it's important one is um Mr Putin tried
to justify his so-called special
military operation by saying you know
Russia is coming today to have Russian
speakers in places like harikov and
Odessa and mariopa well these are the
very uh cities that Russia is striking
um without any sort of restraint I was
just reminding myself looking at a video
yesterday of how a Russian missile
strike came straight into the historic
district of Odessa into that big
Orthodox Cathedral so if this is their
version of protecting Russians well God
help Russians elsewhere in the world
look the other uh thing here I should
mention because I am seated here in the
United States we just finished while
we're in the middle of the UN week and
uh Mr zielinski's visit to Washington is
that for the ukrainians to finish what
they started declare full Victory and
push the Russians back so that they no
longer are a threat not only to NATO
countries Europe but the rules-based
International System is that two things
need to happen in Washington number one
is that um the the decision makers there
need to get over their fear of the
nuclear black male in other words Mr
Putin turning to nuclear weapons I don't
think that will happen and number two
there also seems to be concern in
Washington about Russia somehow
imploding if there's too many threats
made to them especially by the
ukrainians I think that is nonsense uh
also but one quick point if I may what
we're seeing Play itself out in Europe
is that European countries actually have
acting ahead of United States for
example providing main battle tanks uh
Jets um those long-range missiles so
that is a very uh refreshing thing to
see and I think they realize that
they're much closer to the front line
Russia is much bigger of a threat and
they need to address it proactively now
Donald what do you think of that because
we do have U.S media reports that Joe
Biden is preparing to send a small
number of long-range missile systems
called attackums what festival do they
do how might that change the the State
of Affairs for Ukraine and how indeed
might Russia then respond to it
well I think what is important is they
can head further deeper into areas where
uh you know Ukraine didn't have uh the
capability before it received uh the
Storm Shadow and Scott missiles so that
hates uh you you know Ukraine is to hit
further be behind what we call Behind
Enemy Lines because what happened was
when ukrainians received the the himars
they moved uh a lot of their sort of
control and communication and some of
their ammunition Depots further behind
and these missiles would allow Ukraine
to hit at uh at control Communications
and also logistical support that is
helping with the military campaign so it
is really very helpful and very
important
um I mean the question of whether they
would hit Russian territory I think uh
you know is is a delicate one but it's
one that should not sort of paralyze
um sort of support for Ukraine because
what we are seeing is that you know that
first of all it is necessary an
essential for Ukraine to receive these
weapons to carry on more effectively
it's military campaign and second you
know Russia threatens a lot but has
limited capabilities unless it escalates
uh much further Joseph territory which I
think they will not do so they will
continue responding in the way they have
responded so far I mean what one of the
real concerns is if these War drags on
for very very long but I don't see that
Russia would sort of escalate to what
level which is really threatening which
we will talk about in sort of the
nuclear territory as a result of
receiving knowing the other accounts I
think that's not a you should be worried
about Andre to what extent does the use
of Western weapons in this war provoke
Putin
uh well
um actually I think that uh
the weapons that are coming from the
West uh this is one of the source of the
prolongation of this uh this uh War uh
the
quantity is rather huge and uh well uh
of course uh uh it gives the opportunity
for the regime in in queue to go on uh
but still are quite sure that in some
period of time uh the people will be fed
up with these uh War conditions uh in in
Ukraine uh maybe not we will win but the
Ukraine we present a regime will fall
and there will be quite new
opportunities for us not to use weapons
against each other but uh to use the
opportunity to make 80 I know Ukraine I
was living there for many years I was in
school and I had plenty of friends uh
there and I have the information which
again myself not by magazines or
newspapers something else I'm preparing
information directly from the ukrainians
including the western part of the of the
of the Ukraine and I think that the
situation uh well is rather negative and
uh okay the people are waiting for this
for the stoppage of this uh you know of
this war I'm just going to jump in there
because we've just got a minute or so
left and Michael last word to you how
long can Ukraine keep defending itself
well it should be defending itself for
as long as it needs to the West allies
should be providing Ukraine with
everything it needs because once again
we are seeing Mr Putin weaponize food uh
migration uh to you know the the trade
with the world and um if the ukrainians
are not given everything they need I
assure you that this war will come to
the doorsteps of many people around the
world it already is in terms of higher
food prices higher Petra prices much
more insecurity so look uh you Mr
zielinski has made it clear here in the
United States and more recently to
Canada is that they're not going to give
up one inch of territory to the Russians
I think the Russians should get that
into their heads and uh do the proper
thing and just pull back to the 1991
borders and um otherwise they risk a lot
more damage to their society to their
lands especially with these new missiles
arriving there we do have leave our
discussion today thank you very much to
all our guests for joining us Andre
Backlund of domitila sagaramuso and
Michael borsaku
and thank you to for watching you can
see this program again anytime by
visiting our website that's
aljazeera.com for further discussion do
go to our Facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash AJ Inside
Story and you can also join the
conversation on X our handle is at AJ
inside story from me Laura Kyle and the
whole team here it's bye for now
foreign